so I've been coming here for 27 years
about 15 of those years I've been coming
as a human rights activist anti-putin
activist
um trying to point out the Russian
government's criminality and to warn
Western businesses about getting
involved in Russia
um this year has been a crazy year
because the world economic Forum last
year said to me that if you want to come
back to Davos you have to pay 250 000.
I'm a human rights activist and they
wanted to charge me 250 000 just to be
to be a formal delegate to be a formal
delegate in Davos and you can buy a
small house in America for 250 000 I'm a
human rights activist they wanted to
charge me that money for money to enter
their conference Hall what does that say
about Davos
um well it says that that this is a
total profit maximizing organization
their their motto committed to improving
the state of the world is complete
nonsense and if you walk down the main
Promenade here you'll see the Muhammad
bin Salman uh building
um you know this is a guy who is who has
been very credibly Accused by the US
government of murdering Jamal khashoggi
I mean that this is um you know
authoritarian authoritarian City here
but it's still you still come I come
here because most of the heads of state
come here foreign ministers come here
heads of international organizations
come here and even if I'm not in the
halls of Davos I'm here because I'm
supporting Ukraine I'm fighting Putin
and I'm probably one of the loudest
voices fighting Putin right now
can you just um give people a bit of
background about you know how how
long you have been on this but you know
banging the drum that more people are
now starting to bang at the moment so so
in 2009 my lawyer Sergey magnitsky was
tortured to death and killed in a
Russian prison for uncovering Russian
corruption and since then I've given up
my life as a businessman to focus on
Justice and going after Putin and I've
been coming here year after year
challenging the Russian government and
and warning people this could happen to
you
for for many years I was seen as as some
type of extremists people said yeah you
know you must have some kind of like
issue
um and then February 24th happened and
what what I experienced on an individual
basis with Sergey magnitsky my lawyer
has now been repeated
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of times and the world has
woken up to the fact that
um this is Putin is a is a cold-blooded
killer that's right now are there any
particular kind of levers I mean a lot
of the things that have been discussed
in recent days have been things about
like getting kind of weapons getting
heavy Weaponry tanks and so on to
Ukraine
are there any other angles that we could
be taking to to on this on this conflict
also my my big pitch this year
um is that in after the war started the
West froze 350 billion dollars of
Russian government Central Bank Reserves
it's money held at the bank of England
at the Federal Reserve in the U.S at the
European Central Bank
um the uh Putin regime has created more
than a trillion dollars of damage to
Ukraine and so it seems entirely moral
and logical that that 350 billion
dollars has been frozen should be seized
and should be used for the defense and
reconstruction of Ukraine so this is
money that is sitting right now it's
kind of sitting in the Bank of England's
you're saying that needs to go to
Ukraine that money needs to go to
Ukraine and this and that's just the
beginning of the money in the needs to
go to Ukraine uh Putin broke it he
should fix it and um the Russians should
be the first people to pay for
everything that's being done in Ukraine
and more broadly I mean what still
we're kind of almost a year in now and
you know has this gone on kind of longer
than you would have expected is this
what what how what do you call this now
that we're going through at the moment I
mean this is a quagmire this is this is
a uh a war that's not going to end
anytime soon Vladimir Putin is not going
to give up
um and the ukrainians certainly aren't
going to give up and um and so this is
this war is going to go on and and
um both sides neither has a totally
definitive military advantage
and so this is going to go on and what
Putin is hoping is that we grow tired of
it and we we stop thinking about it we
stopped talking about it but um I'm not
interviewed about it on Sky News uh that
and and that's what some of his friends
have gotten away with Assad in Syria you
know we were all shocked by what he was
doing a decade ago he's still there so
it's about so it's about trying to kind
of normalize this and what your point is
this is very this is very abnormal well
they're they're murdering
you know tens if not hundreds if not
thousands of people on a daily basis and
and um we see it on our television
screens and that can't be allowed it
just cannot this cannot be tolerated uh
in Europe right now that that ukrainians
are being killed by Putin he's murdering
innocent people for no reason other than
his own
selfish desire to stay in power